hello and welcome to crash course cries
fair I'm Tom and I'm Simon and this week
we're moving off the land and onto the
oceans for the formation of sea ice and
I'm gonna be talking about some of the
remarkable physics of water ice and the
fact that it's kind of key for us even
being here and having life on Earth
absolutely let's hope you can bear with
us what is sea ice and how is it
different to land ice or freshwater ice
sea ice occupies about 7% to the world's
oceans and it's very important for the
global energy budget due to its
consistently high albedo albedo is an
important concept and is simply the
proportion of light or radiation that is
reflected from a surface so it's
perfectly white and reflecting
everything is one is perfectly black and
absorbing everything it's zero in order
for sea ice to form the water must be
cooled on his upper surface to the point
where it will freeze solid cooling of
the ocean surface while the atmosphere
would always make that surface water
more dense causing it to sink and
therefore set up convection cells
bringing warmer and less dense water to
the surface this will continue to happen
down to the freezing point in seawater
due to the addition of salt that
freezing point is about minus 1.8
degrees Celsius just as a heads-up
convection is the tendency of cooler and
therefore more dense materials to sink
and warmer and therefore less dense
materials to rise under the influence of
gravity
it may seem then that we have to cool
the entire water column to minus 1.8
before we see any freezing on the
surface however actually the Arctic
Ocean and the Antarctic oceans as well
are stratified into different layers
caused by salinity and temperature
differences and therefore we only need
to cool the top hundred to 150 meters of
water which is a lot less than the total
amount however this is still quite a
large body of water this is one of the
reasons why you see sea ice forming a
little bit later in the winter season
than you would do on a freshwater lake
or a smaller body of water in a similar
climactic condition
we'll be returning to Tom later to talk
about the formation of sea ice in detail
but for now I'm going to abused my power
as the editor of this series because I
want to talk to you about some of the
cool physics of ice the fact that ice is
less dense than water is actually one of
the most remarkable properties about it
as we can see in this model this is a
model of the molecular structure of ice
each vertex we have a water molecule red
being an oxygen atom and white being a
hydrogen atoms so we have h2o and
between them we have these metal bars
now these aren't just here to keep the
thing together
these represent hydrogen bonds between
the water molecules so there are lots of
ways in which molecules can talk to each
other hydrogen bonds are just one way in
which they can do that and the effect of
the hydrogen bonds is to form a
crystalline structure a crystallized
structure has a regular repeated
structure of a definite chemical
composition which actually means that
ice is a mineral because the molecules
of water aren't just mushed together by
other forms of bonding
they actually have space between them it
means that when the water transitions
from a flick wha'd to a solid state the
mean distance between the molecules
actually increases and this means that
the density of ice is less than water
because the same amount of water in
liquid form expands to a greater volume
when it becomes a solid but the mass has
stayed the same so the density has gone
down so not only does this explain why
ice floats on water it's actually key to
white life exists on earth where we
based on another liquid that didn't have
a solid form that was less dense than
its liquid form if the top layer of this
liquid are the exposed to the atmosphere
were to freeze it would then sink and
expose new liquid to the atmosphere
which would then freeze and sink I need
to get the entire world's oceans all the
bodies of water being frozen solid the
fact that ice forms a less dense layer
than the water underneath protects it
seals are in from the effects of a cold
atmosphere this model is actually a
memorial to a PhD student here at spry
Jeremy Bailey who died in 1965 when he
was on an expedition in Antarctica and
his vehicle plunged into a crevasse
killing him and the other two
researchers on board science can be
difficult and perhaps no more difficult
than the science of the cryosphere where
our knowledge has been hard one
sometimes with the loss of life so the
formation of sea ice is an important
process and as always there's more to it
than meets the eye at first sea ice
actually forms differently in calm water
as opposed to rough water in quiet
conditions the first ice to form is a
skim of tiny two to three millimeter
disc shaped individual crystals each
disc has at C axis vertical that is to
say its shortest axis vertical and
continues to grow outwards laterally at
a certain point this shape becomes
unstable and the crystal starts to grow
out in long dendritic arms following a
kind of hexagonal structure that's very
typical as we've seen to water these out
growing arms are very fragile and very
quickly break off even in this calm
water which leaves this kind of mush of
disks and arms all floating around
together on the surface of the water in
quiet conditions these crystals soon
start to freeze together or form a very
thin layer of new young ice this is
called nihlus ice with any kind of
turbulence in the water either from the
wind or maybe tidal action these
fragments get broken up further and the
density of these fragments in the water
increases until they reach a point at
which you have greased ice or phrasal
ice
once this needless ice has formed you
start to get a very different process of
accumulation where water from the sea
freezes onto the bottom of the ice this
happens until the ice is about 11.5
metres thick at which point you have
your young new ice when only a few
centimetres thick this new young ice is
pretty transparent as it grows and grows
however it turns gray and then finally
white the reason why you stop getting
the freeze on of ice below 11.5 meters
thickness is that the cold of the
atmosphere can no longer penetrate the
ice far enough in order to cool the
water enough to freeze it on remember
the ocean water is relatively warm
compared to the atmosphere and once it's
insulated by this layer of ice you're no
longer generating enough cooling in
order to create freezing in rough water
these small phrasal particles cannot
easily bind together and therefore they
increase in density into the point at
which they start to form cakes as these
cakes move around and are sloshed around
in the phrasal ice mixture more more
phrasal ice is frozen on as the ice
crystals bind together this becomes
known as pancake ice because collisions
between the cakes push phrasal ice
that's suspended in the water up onto
the ice which then drains away leaving
frozen ice frozen onto the surround
edge of the cake which end up looking a
lot like a pancake at the ice edge these
pancakes are only a few centimeters in
diameter but the further and further
into the ice pack you move the pancakes
become much larger sometimes between 3
to 5 meters the surrounding phrasal ice
continues to supply material to these
pancakes further into the ice pack where
the wave field has calmed these pancakes
start to collect together and form
consolidated pancake ice this
consolidated pancake ice is your first
year ice such ice is a very different
bottom morphology to the icy ice formed
in caramel water because these flows are
crashing into each other and then being
frozen together like glue with the
nihlus ice you get a very rough bottom
surface and then a top surface that has
craft planes and all sorts of things
going on the top that looks a lot like a
stony field it's often compared to this
is very different to the smooth that's
more traditional cartoon looking sea ice
formed in calm water if any of this
newly formed ice survives the summer
melt season and is not objected by
occurrence down to lower latitudes they
will continue to steadily grow until it
reaches a depth of about 3 meters just
at this 3 meter depth the summer melts
and winter accumulation isn't about
equilibrium interestingly the older the
ice is the less saline it is and
therefore the more resistant and melt it
is this sets of a positive feedback in
terms of melting whereby if you have a
very hot summer and you melt a lot of
the old ice then you ice that then forms
that winter is much weaker and therefore
much easier to melt the following summer
this is one reason why warm summers in
the Arctic are such a problem for sea
ice extent during its lifetime sea ice
is pushed and pulled around a lot by the
wind and the wind is a critical factor
and a lot of sea ice processes and
unfortunately at this point we now have
to go to Simon to do things properly
Abbot Tom how does something like the
wind with something huge and flat like
sea ice well to answer that as in most
things in life we have maths when pushes
sea ice around by a process called
frictional drag now in order to
understand this we're first going to
look at an idealized model so what we
have here is a mass can be anything on a
plane just a flat surface and let's say
we want to move this mass around so we
would loop a row
around it and we give it a tug now what
determines how effective the force
exerted in that rope is in in pushing
that mass around is what's called the
coefficient of friction between the mass
and the plane hopefully this will all
sound familiar to you if you've done a
level maths the light of the coefficient
of friction between two surfaces the
rougher the boundary is and so the
greater the force required to pull or
push the object horizontally across the
surface but in the case of wind pushing
sea ice around we don't have the wind
last suing the ice and pulling it on a
rope instead we just have air masses
blowing away on the top of the ice now
these actually produce a frictional drag
by what's called a boundary condition so
the fact that the velocity of the air up
here is quite large but the fact that
the velocity of the air within the ice
and actually a layer just ever so
slightly above the ice is zero this
produces what's called a vertical wind
shear and when we plug this boundary
condition the velocity being zero at the
surface boundary condition into our
equations we find that there's a
frictional drag exerted by the wind on
the ice now the coefficient of friction
between the air and the ice may not be
huge it's actually quite small but so is
the force that's exerted by the wind by
the frictional drag now if we were
trying to push ice on land nothing would
happen but we're not on land we're
talking about sea ice so underneath our
ice there isn't land there's sea if we
were trying to push ice over the land
then the coefficient of friction between
the ice and the land is so large that a
small force exerted by wind stress just
wouldn't be enough to push the ice
however on the sea the coefficient of
friction between the water and the ice
is low enough that even a small force
exerted by frictional drag especially if
you consider it over a large enough area
is more than enough to push our ice and
see significant movement the key fact
here then is the boundary condition
between the air moving over the ice in
the air being stationary in the ice and
the fact that we have two interfaces one
of which is between the ice and the
water which has a very low coefficient
of friction
the wind stress that drives the sea ice
through frictional drag could be
gathered from very large areas up to 400
kilometers upwind since Isis a little
strength under tension cracks can open
up in there flows these cracks are
called leads and rapidly refreeze during
winter this is due to the big
temperature difference between the water
which is about minus 1.8 degrees Celsius
and the atmosphere which could be at
around minus 36 degrees Celsius or even
less the heat loss for a newly opened
lead could be so violent something in
the region of a thousand watts per meter
squared and it's as though steam was
exploding from the surface this steam is
actually frozen water vapor as the
surface water comes into contact and
evaporates very quickly with a very cold
air this newly opened lead
freezes very rapidly and when the wind
fields become convergent again this is
the first part of the flow to be crushed
in this way we start to form what's
known as pressure ridges which have huge
sales going up into the air a couple of
meters and it's been even known that the
keel of the pressure Ridge can go down
to about 50 meters below the ice these
ridges in the Arctic can actually make
up quite a large amount of the ice mass
some estimates have it around 40 to 60
percent of the ice mass of the Arctic
ice is actually contained in these big
pressure ridges that have been formed in
as the flows crashed together because of
these leads and ridges the landscape of
the Arctic Ocean is not just a plain
white sheet but it's an ever-changing
system of walls and valleys and rough
patches and smooth patches that
constantly changes this is one of the
big challenges for the early explorers
of the Arctic was navigating this
chaotic landscape this whole array of
formation melting opening and closing
postures through a whole selection of
cyclical processes largely based on the
seasonal melt season without a changing
climate it's in looking increasingly
likely that we're going to lose the vast
majority of our Arctic ice cover a
significant amount of sea ice cover in
the Antarctic as well sea ice isn't the
only thing in the series that was made
on water because in front of us we have
what it might look boring but it's quite
an interesting wooden box really and it
contains lots of lovely geological
specimens yes I said it's a bit like a
sweet box but you
now if you want to keep your teeth in
tax no although the folks who collect
that this might have wanted anything to
eat
so this is from the aurora expedition
which was from 1911 to 1914 you might
have heard of Shackleton they had this
great plan to go send one ship to one
side of Antarctica when another ship to
the other side and then he would walk
across meanwhile the other people would
lay deppoh so he had food to meet up
with sadly it all went a bit wrong
Shackleton the ship got crushed on the
ice and he managed to get all of his
folks back in one piece
meanwhile the Aurora crew were left
expecting Shackleton to turn up and
laying their Depot's and doing a bit of
science so that's where this box comes
from but actually there's quite a long
history of collecting geological
specimens in polar regions so we've got
things that go back so into the 19th
century and it was just part of your
exploration you would go out you would
map a new bit of coastline you'd collect
some zoological specimens you collect
some geological specimens and now a lot
of this material sits in museum
collections perhaps not doing an awful
lot but it's still here for research so
we've been accumulating this kind of
layers and layers of scientific evidence
and it really is the evidence that we
use for learning about the world so I
mean this is what the days when the
choir is such a new thing every
expedition you were required to pick
fruit from every possible tree and this
is just so the geological picking so
these these are all different rocks
absolutely yes and yeah so you're
absolutely right they would go and do a
little bit of everything and certainly
the 19th century it was all about the
gentleman scientist who had this very
broad wide-ranging education and would
be expected to be able to draw quite
well so he could capture his information
like that know which rock specimens to
collect and how to label them up so yeah
it's going back to the box make a box I
think they had quite a lot of time on
their hands yeah but so this was this
was made on the Aurora yeah I don't know
where the woods came from it might have
been a box that they took with them but
yeah it's from it dates from that
expedition so it's possible they took
the box with them or they did have
carpenters on board so plenty to do with
what not enough to do yeah indeed
so talking about the gentle and
scientist one of the fields which I
haven't talked about in this series at
all is oceanography sister
mmm-hmm is and there's a link to the
ocean of oceanographic sciences here as
well yeah so they'd collect their rocks
they collect their animals they collect
any floor they found they also did daily
measurements of temperature growth of
the water and of the air salinity levels
there how much salt there was and in the
nineteenth century they did recordings
that they collected all of this
information that later led to our
understanding of the Gulf Stream for
instance so yeah it all adds up to help
us build our theories and its knowledge
which we're still very much applying now
yeah and we've got people here in the
Institute who've done research where
they've gone back to historical records
in order to compare them with what we
have today so a lot of the climate
science that we have uses this 19th
century stuff as a kind of benchmark so
you can see what the trends are and how
things have shifted was this the
earliest point in history where people
were taking that rigorous measurements
like that certainly the earliest point
where there were a lot of people doing
it so mid 19th century sadly we lost
Franklin and his crew there are two
ships that were lost and as a result of
that lots of you went looking for them
and pretty much everyone went looking
for them did some recording of data so
there was something like 200 trips to
the Arctic in the 19th century and over
half of them published novel scientific
results in this oceanic focused episode
we've covered the formation of sea ice
and how it differs in rough and calm
conditions the fact that ice is less
dense than liquid water and that this is
key to life existing on earth that sea
ice is mobilized by the wind through a
vertical wind shear and the boundary
condition that the air is not moving in
the ice combined with the low
coefficient of friction between sea ice
and the ocean underneath and lastly that
the Arctic landscape isn't boring it's a
fascinating ever-changing sea ice
landscape with lots of different
features well we barely made it through
that one didn't we we hope you enjoyed
this episode
and that you've learned a few things
about the cryosphere but if you'd like
to learn more there's always more to
learn and some of it is down in the
description there's lots of links to
further reading and if you have a
particular question about what we've
talked about in this episode then Tom
and I will be in the comments section
answering your questions for two hours
after this video is uploaded
thank you for watching but also thank
you to all of these pea
or who helped make this series possible
it really wouldn't exist without them in
particular the recover project at the
University of Exeter and the Scott Polar
Research Institute here in Cambridge
thank you so much for helping us make
this series we'll see you next time
take care bye bye